実は洗濯物が嫌いすぎて乗車さんにやってもらってます肇社長です
あの心霊スポット色々言ったんですけども考えですね身近なところに
すっげーシンディスポットっていうのは隠れているようでしてご覧ください奴ら
正式名称は違うと思うトトロの森っております来て岩が入ってたんだよねめっちゃ
やべえ神です蛍運用面ちゃーんって言っててペンちゃんウェンちゃーん
venture さん本当にヤバいんだよって言ってサボがなんか本当に声出す来て中
に祠があるみたいな話を聞いております
いきますか
はほらなんかこういう感じで奉ってあるんだよ本当のあ
怖いねぇ
怖いですね
僕の行くかそれ h
いきます
アポジションっ
あった
カバため食べ方ですねっ
まあからてもやばいやばいよ確かにちょっと今度は強すぎて月って早い時間に行って
しまいました
ずっと間違えたぜってー何
ありませ服スーツ制服ございますはい
は連れてそれだああ
あっ終わったあっは
くるところで見るくらいかあそうすごいビデオ食べる
そんなすごいんですねすごいよいいよ
上がってくださいこの先深いですよちょっと怖いよ気持ちでいきますは
と言っています頑張ってください
は振り返らない
このそっち行けないっ
アップ力た jさんの足でそこって俺の指あたりじゃないですか
ねっ
はいいやこれ買えるかなぁ
はい
あこんにちはー
ああいう同社は僕はからねこの距離からとか確かに
ってマジで怖いどっから始めたので
まあマってすごいねー
ね q 2進数母艦でできます
ん
んあっ塗りますこれだけでくださいて泣きついたんですけど
明るいんでまだかろうじて見るレベルでに参りますがすごいもうここだ
桜は待って本当には入っちゃってばっかの石が落ちている
いっ
退かぬ身に見せるでも
上ハーフいやいやつリアや
みてくださいこのうん
にほんの木とず味方が何買ってくる声
思えは強い意向いや処分
ここだよ30名前があるみたいと思うと辛子の森だし上に前座があるみたい
なぜ怖いのこの道夜道を
登りますか思いますなんか造語に言うと誰からここで足を引っ張られたと言う事を聞き
ます
まずで怖いんだけど
治安も悪いよ
鳥居が見えてきました川の中にそういう森ガール度は凄いよね
あ終わったり以外これなそうですねいやーまってまってこい
強すぎですこの時間でこの強さってやばいする上でいいん
もっとぞってドットってとっとっていました
えっ
していません
葉っぱ登っています
本当に強いいやーもう weiner
この多くにた分祠があるぽいシーンとこだと思う
dj 一体一さんじゃないですか
怖すぎるバールが見える見ます
ねえねえっ
地下たとおやめくださいん
マックいざしようかと思っていますん
うえん
ホラーです
それじゃあこれウへ登りたくないよまず目に入って来ないんだ
も頑張って登っていう来なく母だ p ベースんだけど怖い怖い怖いこうやっていい
場所なんだろうけど怖い
見ていっ
なあ空2つでニュースポットもしれませんねうわぁ
擦れるへと入りぺっぺだうそれはすごいを嗅がせたッ
自然左から視線を感じるんだけど文鳥肌立っ
本当は
脱毛さんに鳥肌立つない
いけな山々てを疑ってるきみてみたいですねー
おっ
空を切って書いてあります naoki だけ z 許されねぇこれはん子染色まだ
カードはもう過ぎてません
シップっぽい同郷なお皿ちまん
6石井石井氏
ぽんって投げといないじゃ以内に立ってるほら女帝がカメラと思ってますじゃないから
まずん